It's time for The Muppets
Take Unemployment.
The Muppets Take Unemployment.
(cheering, applause)
Wait a minute.
Hey, stop.
Why are you clapping? You don't
even know what you're cla...
You're clapping for the fact
that ABC canceled The Muppets!
-(booing)
-Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, you can suck it, ABC,
unless I can work for you.
But... there's one thing I know:
it's that the Muppets
will be back on TV and movies
and the Internet and other
future forms of entertainment
that we haven't even invented
yet until the end of time.
And I say that is fantastic.
So let's do some brainstorming.
I would like you
to give me the names
of as many future
Muppet projects as you can
that hopefully will get made.
I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock. And begin.
-Kristen.
-Uh. Dr. Bunsen Honeydew
in The John Hodgman Story.
All right. Points.
Yes, I see it!
Hodgman.
Pigs in Space:
the Fork Awakens.
All right, points.
Fozzie.
Uh, an Animal House remake
with Animal!
Yeah, points.
Kristen.
Gonzo Girl.
Yes, points. Fozzie.
Miss Piggy
in Silence of the Hams.
All right, perfect.
Ah.
-Oh.
-Hodgman.
A new HBO political comedy
called Meep.
Oh, perfect! So good!
So good. Fozzie.
Um, anything,
as long as I have a job.
Yeah, points. Points.
-Obviously!
-Obviously, yeah.